[Music]
when you
there are two types of things in the
universe
those who dance and those who do not
I get it yes I am a dancer Cory is not
you just need to find a woman who is
pathetic like you thanks boy do you need
a hug no no I do not oh I thought I said
you're welcome
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie we got that
guardians of the galaxy teaser trailer
I'm so happy so let's break it down this
is so great so you guys may know some of
the things that are going on with the
movie based on what happened around
comic-con so we got dancing baby Groot
like at the very end it's kind of like
the spider-man moment just like almost
like a post-credits scene for the actual
teaser itself we're sitting on rocket
shoulders a nice reversal from the first
movie where Groot was huge and rocket
was tiny sitting on route shoulders he
sees him hallway shots in the Milano
some fun graffiti the hooked on a
feeling song I think they actually used
for the first guardians of the galaxy
movie trailer so it's kind of a fun way
of them flipping the themes of the first
trailer while showing you the old family
getting back together like the bands
getting back together Gamora at what
looks like a pretty badass space portal
yondu with his new fin and rocket
looking like they're escaping a bunch of
Ravagers in the comic-con trailer
yondu had actually been captured by the
Ravagers like they'd turned on him and
that was why he had to join the
guardians so part of the fun of that
comic-con trailer was him getting his
fin back because that's the way he
controls his weapon like it glows when
he's whistling but we have nebula she's
back so happy Karen Gillan's back she's
actually gonna be with the guardians
there's gonna be a lot of nice Gamora
nebula scenes Peter quill putting the
mask back on look at the color in this
shot this is why I love James Gunn so
much because not only is he really good
with composition or riding really cool
stories or characters he's also really
good with visuals so this almost looks
like a painting here more Ravagers
getting the ship blown out of them the
Ravagers are actually more villains in
this movie than they were in the first
movie this is really cool this is
actually from a scene in the comic-con
trailer where they go to meet Peter
Quill's father ego the Living Planet
teasing a little bit of romance between
star-lord and Gamora I'm totally fine
with it but usually in the comics they
tend to pair him with other characters
like they paired him with Kitty Pryde
who's obviously an x-men character that
they can't do in the movies they paired
him a little bit with Captain Marvel so
you guys can let me know what you think
about star-lord Gamora romance in this
movie you just need to find somebody
who's just as pathetic as you this part
was so great
our two types of people in this universe
people who dance people who don't the
funny thing is is that in the deleted
scenes for guardians of the galaxy one
Gamora does do the dance-off when
they're trying to get the Infinity stone
so she actually does dance a little bit
I'd always loved those Drax hugs
it looks like Drax is much more in touch
with his emotions in this movie baby
Groot peeking out there's a funny
montage in the comic-con trailer where
he like comes back with a bunch of
random items trying to steal yondu's
Finn so they can escape the Ravagers
prison so maybe that'll be in the next
big trailer they release so the thing is
is the reason they're probably releasing
this now is because they're dropping the
big trailer with dr. strange usually
they're released like a short teaser
trailer before they release the actual
big trailer so just expect the next 10
days or so whenever Doctor Strange drops
to get like the full thing which is
actually earlier than I thought I didn't
think this would drop til Star Wars
rogue one which is in December so we're
getting at like a whole month before I
thought we were gonna get it this is
amazing
I'm so happy and I cannot wait to see
this movie so if you guys don't know
when it's coming out it's a may movie
instead of like guardians of the galaxy
one which was an August movie so just
for Marvel we have guardians of the
galaxy coming in May then we have
spider-man homecoming in July and then
in November we have Thor Ragnarok so
there are three Marvel movies coming
next year if you guys didn't know and
that's just for Marvel there are a bunch
of other comic-book movies coming so it
is gonna be awesome but what's gonna
happen is I have some Deadpool I have
agents of shield there's more DC this
week so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and I am gonna do a new round
of the Marvel giveaway because I'm so
happy so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so goodnight and
if there's any guardians of the galaxy
bonus videos that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments
changing the outro just a little bit so
while you guys wait for my next video
you can click up top for the last big
Doctor Strange trailer teasing the
multiverse and you can click down here
to learn what's going on the spider
homecoming trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight there are two types
of things in the universe